What's next, Rossy?
Well, up next,
have you all seen the new "Spider-Man" movie?
Hello?
Yes!
(crowd applauds)
Like, the biggest grossing movie ever.
Love it!
Well, you might wanna go back and see it again.
Because apparently, there's a little Easter egg,
a little something hidden in there.
Two Easter eggs, I hear.
Uh-huh, you'll get it.
Wait, I'm...
Yeah, nevermind.
You'll get it.
People reports Tom Holland...
Shoot.
People reports Tom Holland told Seth Meyers that,
you know that big scene where he appears with,
spoiler alert, the past Spider-Men,
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield?
Well, he said one of them
was wearing a fake butt.
Yes!
(audience gasps)
Under that Spidey suit.
But Tom won't say who.
He says you gotta figure that out for yourself.
So there they are.
Now, I have studied this. No.
(Ross laughs)
(audience laughs)
Was this your homework, Rossy?
Yeah, I gotta do it!
Well, one of them, do you think it's Tobey Maguire
or do you think it's Andrew Garfield
who wore this fake butt?
Fake butt under their Spidey costume?
I don't know.
But I love that there is a fake butt,
sort of, focus.
A conspiracy really, out there.
Well again, like, these are,
you know, when you need a break from everything,
focusing on whose butt in "Spider-Man" has a little,
you know, extra oomph,
that is a subject I could go down a rabbit hole in.
Yeah, you know, there's a lot of news out there,
and I just chose to focus on this.
Okay? Understand?
And I think about, if I was ever in a Spider-Man suit.
I should say, "When I'm in a Spider-Man suit."
(Drew and audience laugh)
Would I pad anything?
You know? I mean, think about that.
Yeah, I think I would.
(audience laughs)
Would you wear a little like, jockstrap or what?
I would wear, you know, if I could,
I would pad some muscles.
You know what I mean?
Oh, I went straight somewhere else, sorry.
(audience laughs)
Well, sometimes I do look at those suits
and think, "Oh, it's relatively smooth."
I've thought that way since the theater
when I was a kid.
Those Shakespearean plays, who are we kidding?
(Ross laughs)
They wore tights, men wore tights,
and it's smooth, and it's weird.
When you're a man in tights-
What makes it so smooth?
You don't want a woman to look at you
and say "You look relatively smooth."
(audience laughs)
That's not a compliment.
Does no one go to the ballet and think,
"That's weird."
(Ross and audience laughs)
Am I the only one thinking like this?
No, you're just the only one saying it.
Who would go to the ballet,
or watch something, or a superhero,
or any man in tights and not gone, "Huh."
"Huh."
(audience applauds)
Is it just me?
Well...
I wanna thank you for being brave enough
to say that, Drew.
Well done.
I'll just say what everybody's thinking.
(Ross laughs)
(upbeat music)